it depends I've only stated in a ever
beaten me once I did ayahuasca in
Topanga so I rented like a place out
there and it was expensive yeah a lot of
money did you feel did that do you feel
like that that experience was pretty
cool would you do it again I'm glad I
did it I think I will do it again he
didn't give me a ton the first night but
I puked the entire first night and I
think commedia it's just a lot of prom
date set after prom sorry that's too
easy too much I've you know what it
wasn't but that's brave that you did
that that why did you do it it wasn't
that easy to joke that you're a sexual
predator right in this getting your sick
hiding in plain sight just like I like
the idea that you're just cuz like guys
right now I'm obsessed with the guys
that have sexually harass women but they
haven't been called out and they might
be a little annoyed because it means
that they're not famous enough right
there's something funny about someone
being like I mean no one's asked me like
what the [ __ ] I like you know I like
just because you have to have a hot
career right now to kind of go down
that's true yeah maybe this is such a
blessing I'm sort of just you're right
underneath you can still sex your as
people and kind of like you're sort of
in the money zone right now
do you um but do you think she oh no
you're asking me about ayahuasca I would
do it again the first night it's
interesting because like first time I
did it I was like oh I feel like on some
level cuz comics what we do is we
overanalyze things or we see them from
like nine different places you know like
different facets or we like you know
have this oppositional thing where we
take the unpopular argument and prove it
like right we should you know and I felt
like I wast got a little bit it was like
oh I feel like ayahuasca helps people
who aren't comedians just think like
comedians oh and then I felt like I just
thought like a normal person it was
weird
it turned off a lot of stuff yeah and
there was a lot of stuff that I just
realize like masturbatory thoughts and
like the old tapes in our heads and the
old stories they just kind of stopped
playing because like a spring cleaning
almost that's right yeah exactly exactly
it's just like it's just deleting some
of that static you know and then I
realize
like and then I was a chill and all I
was doing I was like oh look at his
shoes like look at this wall and I was
like I feel like this is how normal
people think they just think about like
one thing at a time they don't like
overanalyze that or have to make a joke
about it was like four hours where I
wasn't thinking of jokes right you know
it's like clear and it's kind of
peaceful oh my yeah it was just kind of
like chill and then the second night I
puked a bunch but I had a couple little
breakthroughs that I feel like I would
have come to my own at some point in my
life but this kind of just expedited it
yeah you know yeah right but yeah it's I
get almost City yet it's like oh [ __ ]
this might have took me three years to
get through some of this stuff
especially the old tapes that you don't
see it's like it becomes their gremlin
that's kind of dancing over yeah that's
right and you're so used to it that it
doesn't even occur to you yeah that you
know it's crazy as my sister can't even
read but what does it have to do with us
right now hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option not this
guy two options watch one this one or
this one